[Music]
caravan after Caravan is forming
unvetted illegal aliens trying to flood
into our country on your dollar
overwhelming your school's depleting
your resources and endangering your
community they're telling you the
existential threat to America is a bunch
of poor refugees a thousand miles away
they're even taking our brave troops
away from their families for a political
stunt well there's the back and forth on
the campaign trail as you see the
president and the former president back
and forth the president is finishing
this campaign blitz in West Virginia
Indianapolis tonight Montana Pensacola
Florida tomorrow Georgia Tennessee on
Sunday Ohio Indiana and Missouri on
Monday but he's also riding a wave of
good economic news America now has the
best economy in the history of our
country and we want to keep it that way
in the last month alone we added this
just came out a few hours ago 250,000
jobs that's in the month of October by
the way that's for one month and nearly
half a million Americans return to the
workforce we've created 4.5 million new
jobs since the election so that October
jobs report was stellar even critics of
the president say yeah it's pretty good
250,000 jobs 3.7 49-year low for the
unemployment rate if you look at the
changes in the economy since the
president took office GDP growth
unemployment rate real bump and consumer
confidence and average hourly earnings
are up which is a big deal as well so
with all of that let's bring in our
panel
Josh crush our is political editor for
National Journal
Molly Hemingway senior editor at The
Federalist and Charles Lane an opinion
writer for The Washington Post okay Josh
you know we haven't heard that much
about the economy on the trail today's
jobs number clearly is a closing
argument for some of these Republicans
yeah I mean that's part of the problem
from the White House that you don't hear
the president talking as much about the
economy as he is about immigration and
you know in the red states and in
Missouri Indiana West Virginia
I mean immigration is a pretty potent
issue and is something that is rallying
the conservative base but when you look
at the House map and you're looking at
you know how many seats could end up
flipping in suburban areas that are just
a little bit uncomfortable with that
anti-immigration anti-illegal
immigration rhetoric there's a lot of
Republican strategist that are wondering
why President Trump's not talking about
all the good economic news and focusing
so much on immigration Molly well as
James Carville noted it's the economy
stupid people really are motivated
particularly when the economy is bad
when when things are not going well
people very much want to throw the bums
out I think the main significance of the
economy being so good and it's been
really good for a while now is that it
has tempered that desire to throw the
bums out or completely change the
management of the country and a lot of
it is just directly tied to Republican
policies whether it's tax cuts or
regulatory pullback or you know any of
any of the other things that the Trump
administration and Republicans in
Congress have done and particularly
noteworthy I think is the increase in in
hourly wages a lot of times we've had
good economic news where it seems to
benefit the wealthy and not necessarily
trickle down this is really good for for
employees and people throughout the
economic speaking of the immigration
issue in one race in Missouri it is
playing interestingly the incumbent
Democrats speaking about supporting
President Trump take a listen and what
do you do when they get to the border
what do you do I think the president has
to use every tool he has at his disposal
and I'm a hundred percent back him up on
that whether it is turning them back
because we are not equipped to handle
that many asylum claims into our system
if you're for it
take your name today take your name off
Diane Feinstein's open borders bill
Claire McCaskill sponsoring that bill in
the United States Senate she has been
for months so put your money where your
mouth is take your name off the bill do
it right now you know Chuck the
Republicans call it the open borders
bill it's actually not called that but
it is a bill that feinstein every
democrat signed on to and it essentially
has this thing that says you can't
arrest anybody within 100 miles of the
border even for anything if they're an
illegal alien you know my reaction to a
lot of the things the president has been
saying over the last week is that he is
playing on people's fears particularly
with respect to this caravan which will
probably peter out long before it gets
to the border having said that he's not
doing it by accident he's doing it
because the fears exist and Claire
McCaskill's interview with you
epitomizes that perfectly I believe Joe
Donnelly is saying similar things in
Indiana and he understands that in red
states he has Democrats on the defensive
and with respect to that bill that just
illustrates the Democrats inability so
far to come up with a popular message
regarding immigration that speaks about
the issue in a way that's both positive
toward immigration and capable of
gaining a majority instead you have
people like Claire McCaskill kind of
running away from the National Party and
the washington-based party and their
message and I think that if there's any
hope or saving grace for that within it
for the Democrats it has to do with
Josh's point about the suburbs I think
the red hot stuff that the president is
presenting on immigration may be turning
off moderate and and and more moderate
Republicans and women in the suburban
districts that they need to all will see
and we'll see how much the economy and
this final jobs report moves people one
way or another I want to put up the
Power Rankings as of tonight before I
get race by race in the Senate we have
it really the same as we've had it 50
Republicans 45 Democrats this takes a
look at the races the liens the likely
is we have five toss-up races there that
will decide
the balance of power there in the house
it keeps shifting thirty-one toss-up
races now we have it down to 29
you need to 18 for the majority that is
where the Democrats are better
positioned to take over the majority
only need a few more to pick up about 17
to get that if you count the likely s
all right race by race Josh well one of
the House races that I'm looking really
closely at is the sixth District of
Kentucky Mitch McConnell's backyard it's
a trump district he won it by about 20
points but the Democrat who's a
celebrated military veteran Amy McGrath
is running neck-and-neck with the
Republican congressman Andy Barr
McConnell folks are really watching this
race closely it closes early we'll know
the results pretty quickly it's a big
bellwether well I chose Pennsylvania 16
this is the kind of race that if
Democrats win this it will point to them
having a very big night this is a
district that Trump won by 20 that
Romney won by five if you have one poll
with Mike Kelley up and another poll
with Ronda Nicola up and so depending on
how that goes might be an indicator of
the whole evening I tell you those house
polls are tough and you know it's just
not it doesn't seem like it really
sticks all these polls are kind of 1/2
points could really swing each one of
these races well since everybody's using
the number six I have the sixth District
two but in Illinois
seriously it's 666 I don't know Peter
Roskam is the incumbent Republican he's
been there since 2006 and Republicans
have held this seat since 1972 through
all the blue waves that went to and fro
in that time but Roskam is in the race
in his life against Democrat Shaun
Caston and this is one of those races
that really epitomizes because it went
for Hillary Clinton
this district went for Hillary by seven
points last time around a lot of
Republicans retired rather than run in
districts where Hillary won Roskam is
giving it a try if he can't pull it off
there I think it's going to show there's
a long night ahead for Republicans
because it's a tip it's typical of those
bellwether
now purple suburban districts that the
Republicans have to hold that they're
going to have any hope of keeping image
ours